come winter Brian and Barbara say
they'll live in their Lounge heating
just one room their answer to Rising
energy bills I usually put an extra
jumper on or or socks or something like
that you know or really jogging trousers
anything to sort of keep me a bit warmer
Brian even sleeps on the sofa and talk
of NHS pressures is troubling him I had
a heart attack many years ago
um and you're more prone to that so I'm
a bit worried that the ambulance can't
respond quite quick enough if I need the
problems what'll happen when you get
into hospital I don't want to sit around
for hours on end waiting for a bed in an
ambulance Corridor a corridor or
something a little further down the road
and their neighbor Rafi and his family
are enjoying the summer but they're
worrying too about winter and Rafi can't
afford to heat all his house I might
switch my office to the kids bedroom so
that you know I can work together we
have seen that during covet periods and
lengthy waiting and if it has put
pressure on the NHS system probably
I'm really worried will go back to the
same stages yeah and what would that
mean what does that look like long
waiting periods even I'm not so sure how
long it's going to take the GP
appointments they're not the only ones
worried over a hundred Health leaders
have written to the chancellor they say
rising Energy prices will cause a public
health emergency going into a winter
that looks like it's going to be very
tough if we add into that more people
who are unable to heat their homes uh
we'll also see more people getting sick
and we'll see more demand and that is
going to be a problem for the health
service for all of us who use the ulcer
and it's even tougher for those with
chronic long-term illness Tammy Prescott
has incurable stomach cancer with the
chemoid you get really cold and you feel
the cold and and a cold person on there
and quite a hot blooded person so it's
never bothered me before but now looking
at it it's a case of well I know I'm
going to have to have the heating and I
know I'm going to have to be able to
have that the government says every
household will get 400 pounds towards
fuel with extra help for the most
vulnerable but senior NHS staff say more
is needed if we're to prevent a
humanitarian crisis this winter Laura
bundock Sky News